beh a tutti i ragazzi questo video sono
famiglie oggi siamo con ciccio è pietro
per il finale tirata e volevo essere un
po narrativo però non so se è passato il
concetto la vita lo stesso colore
lo giuro abbassa la musica di sottofondo
il gioco gli effetti ambientali
l'ultima volta tantissimo va bene niente
continuamente lo zucchero poi si sentiva
chi c o parlare
ciao amico e se ne trova in tutto
seconda che farà il compound rencontres
oggi sono incazzato lo dico il primo
flamini catone spingeva la picchiata
entra entra a maledizione è come ciccio
non l'avrebbe detto aspetta aspetta è
come ecco l'operaio non c'è l'acqua è lo
sapevo non c'è acqua io appena nato
l'acqua manco fosse così importante
l'arco va bene sentite io il piccione
arrivato malissimo con cui oseary un col
volume perché contrario di quello che
dice pietro non sento niente allora io
in questo episodio qua se vi ricordate
dovevo pizzicare i mattoni per fare io
dove sto facendo il muro di sopra che
ora non mi ricordo come si fa mattone
secco si è seccato il mattone con la
pioggia il mattone salcone possibile
cioè i mattoni secchi allora spiega devo
riaprire tutto il tutorial o to build
antenna
mi servono 8 planck 6 plastica due
circuiti madre come si fa circuito madre
un polmone cinque assi di ferro e perché
non roditore dai ragazzi sopraffatto da
un prigioniero para papà papà io direi
che possiamo provare a fare la fornace e
così posso costruire quel maledettissimo
ricevitore ce ne andiamo da questo non
c'è anche gli piace molto stare qua mai
zitto ti servono tre rottami raga 3
rottami e da me li perfetto manovra
tranquillo pre con editrice l'abbiamo
creata ci abbia messo sei anni man con
grande jack prego e parlamento sul
tavolo
basta il sito che caci niente con questo
file ap wow che tira me lady ha messo a
me dentro persone michele rai coop per i
giorni di sopravvivenza 14 quella che ci
stiamo
hai rotto le palle sull'isola vai vai
ciccio vai nel tuo momento rame o subito
bravo raccogli ricapitolando è il
progetto antenna è prossima al
ricevitore servono per creare l'antenna
ricevitore che ci portano via dall
oceano ci fanno trovare la terraferma il
problema che per farlo ci servono queste
cose che sto facendo
c'è un problema di inizio fra vai
sull'isola cosa sta facendo la scuola
cosa le dico lo ripeto c'è un ora
cambiano
cosa hai fatto
ma sì ma basta san lorenzo io nella mia
vita ho fatto tante cose ma ora mi trovo
qua con te a pagaiare che arrivi di
niente mi ricordo i tempi quando pescano
come è derivata la voce cosina jonas è
perché guardo un sacco di video di
ciccio merlino quel credito che urla da
ya faccione da quello che odia le donne
ora me lo ripeto va va bene allora
secchio raccolta di 200 perino 15 3 ok
scheda tecnica per carla servono due
lingotti di rame che non ho più servirà
mesi rame prova mi prendi rame ciccio
prendi nome lavora
no allora per prendere il rame devi
andare tipo intorno all'isola qui subito
capito ragazzi compreso il rame e in
braccio prodotto contenitori bravissimo
con i quali la settima quei grandi bravi
[Musica]
mettiamoci non ho ucciso così si gioca
min grazie a questo è falso
aiuto mi sono ancora no la jolie
polinori
no lo accetti un attimo ci mette non hai
capito nino nasi la tua liporace non ho
capito è la mia fornace ragazzi verso il
cielo non li richiama se no io qua una
bella lancia chi si incazza io l'ho col
fisco
ok va bene ciccio solo perché me lo ha
detto lui sono a quest'ora avrei già
litigato litiga litiga l'altro non lo
userei più da fornaci
poi c'è stato è stato dietro mi sultano
povero dice le cose picchiato o ti
racconto il tracciato per la giornata di
oggi mi serve tu hai detto la cpc anzi
faccio una cosa bellissima che rilancia
nel in dell'oceano storia che mi dai
tralci per favore no more letto quasi lo
punterei più milan dicendo tutto i
lingotti ti prendo è una gara una gara
una gara attenzione no ho preso parte
all di bagni si inizia da miliardi da me
dormiamo ragazzi fidate allora crea
scheda elettronica o mio dio vi manca
ancora un circuito per rifare il
circuito mi sono altri di rame li metto
dentro tra liste schifani ad amia
inseriamo ok qui se te li do io ve li do
io tokyo gambe di togliere da me cosi
dal i toni no gesù nutini 12 basta vai
via
continua a cucinare marijuana non mi fa
fare il circa
basta aso e cazzato non possiamo solo
avevano dei bambini è chi beve l'acqua
la rimette chi mangia rimette il cippo
conto era era veritiero nel minimo visto
[Risate]
gli puoi dire di togliersi dalla mia
votazione liceità voglio pescare il
botto a mare e non prendono pesci cazzo
tu te ne esci voglio mangiare ma non lo
posso fare perché sono anti era una
stella cometa vaccino le firme come
fatevi mangiarle tab ci sono robe sotto
ci sono è vero mai buttati mare ma non è
vero
rometti veloce
4 assi di legno attenzione momento della
verità
signori e signori interna o il computer
possiamo andare su facebook router lo
faccio qui sopra con aspetta solo faccia
messo due anni per farlo ecco qui stiamo
navigando cessario serve come batteria
necessaria sì perché vanno a pile i
computer o mamma croce the youtuber
necessario cosa chiesta roba perché ci
sono dei cos'è come funziona il suo
computer
va bene batteria datemi una batteria
luridi una teoria mia lingotto si
parlava telefo trovate ria così così li
così guarda ti piace la mia batteria
guarda bene qualche bella bellissima una
scatola del gelato con le mani ma spero
come si metta a questa la batteria ecco
come sa più cos'è qua antenne a una
intera posso in collegare le antenne
antenne ecco la volt il cardine mauro il
termine posati minerale meta ma ci sono
6 di rame top è a posto
nove sono ricco che ha detto mica posso
fare antenna signori è funziona non ci
servono e non con e quindi devo
connettere trent altre ad ora dai ma che
palle
sapete come si dice papà gay sling
retine no come fa gaio dai riddick e
muori domani ma tuo turello no ora mole
così giovane a zero la fame a 0 tutto a
zero la mia vita 0 let's golf
ci siamo ragazzi scheda elettronica
anthem let's be online
due antenne abbiamo una qua è un ali
accendiamo e la batteria tutto io ho
fatto
rullo 3 1
su coutinho che da che parte è scemo e
scemo quello scemo però la batteria
scende velocissimo kg stai di sbagli
span span span misto che acquistano
tracciato quindi qualcosa in b non di
altro
ma che cos'è non lo so puntava a questo
l'antenna pagaia pagare tassi sono
incastra ormai ci siamo
ci sono se sono esploriamo non c'è un
telefono c'è un telefono pronto
vodafone mafia via via via nelle stanze
moltissimi bar in una cassa lingotti di
metalli lancia in meta al come lingotti
metà lo prendi dopo 42 minuti le date di
lancio sulla zattera guarda sono in
acqua attraversato dal quale sostituto a
quadri saltare la scala sapere o dei
deficienti che bella la nostra zattera
da qua sembra una un atterraggio per
aerei quando avremo ancora più su ci
siamo ci siamo anche fotografie trovate
tre al test casi mondo cosa safe and
safe people show c'è la mappa australia
completamente ricoperta d'acqua
il mondo è ricoperto tutto d'acqua
siamo nel 2028 quindi non c'è terraferma
però vorrei buttarmi perché ho molta
fama la perciò per gli direi che
possiamo concludere queste feature in
iraq the è stato bellissimo grazie a un
viaggio a capire se riuscirà prego se
poi riusciamo a trovare di rotta cieli
sommersi perché la terra si è ricoperta
d'acqua giuliano un prossimo video
ragazzi ciao
[Musica]